[Music]
and savage from my news grandma mm-hmm
submitted by plastic couch cover oh man
I hated those in your house no my
babysitter had it in her
my babysitter had a - did you sit there
and if you're wearing shorts that [ __ ]
sticks it's annoying
all right so a grandma shot her grandson
over an argument about a teacup on her
furniture did he die that's right we
teach our grandson well I was reading he
did not die on the foot
this is discipline then yeah it was just
like this you shot him in the what kind
of gun did she have my grandma yeah a
tough one uh just say a gun so you don't
[ __ ] with grandma's teeth because I
picture at 38 special revolver sorry Oh
looks like a nice one and it's like at
the circus like a cowboy gun yeah
it'll hurt ya 75 year old grandma from
Minnesota she gotten into an argument
with her grandson because apparently his
grandson left a teacup on her furniture
and she was yelling and like move it or
whatever and then he didn't so then she
got up she did what a [ __ ] yeah
right she threw the green tea away so I
was the first cup of tea then this fool
comes and gets another cup he puts it
down
[ __ ] yeah her [ __ ] despite her or how
old is this kid yeah I was 18 seven
there's a difference
eighteen year old he does deserve a shot
in the leg but he don't mention what if
it's his house and she's living in his
house like his parents his house
wouldn't have plastic on that true no no
that's just the person that submitted oh
I know I picture the same thing that I'm
with you yeah like the seventies retro
planet plastic she probably wouldn't be
that upset about Atika because it's
protective like really hot and it's melt
on the plan what's the difference
between a teacup in a mug a smaller yeah
small and she's tripping over that I
mean whatever this is a probably spell
the pies spill all over it was on a wood
table so you put it on a wood table on a
finger ring yeah I was thinking a rink
oh he didn't use a coaster
yeah no coaster so then that's when like
after that second cup like they were
into they were arguing even more she
ended up just bringing out the revolver
and shot him in the leg and she admitted
to the cops she was like well I mean I
am for the leg like I wasn't trying to
kill him she's like I did that what's up
yeah you want to talk she's [ __ ] oh
so this is Helen if you knew how crazy
your grandma was why would you ever
cross her oh I wouldn't even test her oh
she looks crazy
look at her hair she's like no [ __ ]
giving she's like this side of my hair
pissed me off so her hair looks like a
rid of it I heard probably just sub I
feel like there's a lot you can do
before you shoot someone like throw the
hot tea on them you know torture them
first take some fingernails off to get
the bail dude
I mean shooting is a little extreme I'm
even maybe this guy's a piece of [ __ ]
and [ __ ] this is like the straw that
broke the camel's back and she's like
look [ __ ]
it's not about the teacup it's the
[ __ ] principle all right she's been
trying to tell him for the thousandth
time it was like forever
it's like pick up your yeah stop coming
home late stop the [ __ ] stealing my
money from my purse did you guys ever do
anything fucked-up to your grandma no me
my grandma like this my grandma did
[ __ ] up things to me anyway cuz I did
what you do [ __ ]
ah who's got the page a lot of me mom my
grandma was a very tough woman but I
felt neutral about her it wasn't like I
loved your like crazy and I didn't hate
her like only think I love my grandma
okay so I was really little I forgot how
old I think I was like six lemon I know
what I did she was taking care of me
this isn't a date by the way her house
and there was this girl down the street
that she was having this party she
invited me because they're gonna have
like good bounce house and all that and
I was like cool yeah I want to go my mom
went somewhere so my grandma was in
charge of taking care of me so I only
God you got her medication you put it in
her mug and then she like passed out no
try what I did so then I asked her she
was like no you can't go anywhere and it
was like literally like right down the
street I was like fine it's in TJ dude
yeah I know but as a little girl you
don't understand okay true and so um so
then what I ended up doing is I found
these like this really super tiny red
chillies that are [ __ ] spicy I forgot
what they're called but they're super
sweet or maybe yeah the little balls
yeah they're like super spicy so I found
some in the kitchen and I was like you
went up there I'm like hey grandma I
have a surprise for you you she was like
oh I see me okay so then I was like
close your eyes and then so she closed
her eyes I was like open your mouth and
then I was like I have a candy for you
to surprise so then she opens her mouth
and I put it in her mouth and she was
like she was just like like she was
sorry she [ __ ] your ass up
did you sure you're in the way
[Laughter]
if my grandkid did that to me I would
nail that fool to the wall I'm like what
the [ __ ] that's conniving as a mother I
know right I'm so evil it's just you
don't let me go to this party girl
Michael oh yeah oh my just start peeing
in her mouth did you thinking - I can
hold in my grandma's shoes like I would
have for sure pink like what does this
girl up to like I was like shaking
because I was so scared when my mom got
home she promised me they'd take me to
this really cool restaurant the next day
and I was still looking forward to that
and then she was like no I'm not taking
it I think I did get my ass beat but I
think I blocked it yeah remember Black
dolphin no soul back just remember you
three little [ __ ] bang you already
look like a look you got literally
knocked out so you don't remember
kid you have silver teeth [ __ ] can I
have some routines I really did but if
you do that means you were like bad like
if you suck in with summer teeth you do
or like now stay away from her he bites
no no I know the silver team does that
come from because they got knocked out
cuz they have so many cavities every now
and then that's too poor to like afford
the other [ __ ] that's sad though is that
there's mercury and people are getting
mercury poisoning from those yeah that's
crazy well I don't have a backbone they
feel like silver back then like kids
having I wanted that so bad but like
they did too like they were silver but
they were they had mercury in them
because it's before the they like yeah
changed laws and [ __ ] yeah but till this
day my grandma tells a story somebody
well I apologize no I did but till this
day like now she finds it so funny
she's just like oh my god let they did
this to me but she took our daughter she
was like oh how cute yeah they call me
pee pee on my mom side of family your
vengeful I know right it's in your soul
I never did that I'm not that person now
okay meet me and my grandma don't take
anything she's trying to feed you
here's some cake what are you give you
cookies last week but you never fed me
though so that's how I know it's gonna
be oh sure you know what though I had
like what I think was like a alternate
evil personality when I was a kid
because I would my I remember being a
kid and the adults would tell stories of
stuff that I was doing and I was like
you did this last week and I was like I
don't remember that at all and I
couldn't even remember going to their
house that week yeah and and I remember
such vivid memories from my childhood
the and and when I was a kid I could
remember things very detailed too so
when they were like you did this I'm
like I have no memory of that at all no
you have multiple personalities me when
I was a kid I watched a video get to a
lot time you should look in 20 years to
but can you just forget a lot of [ __ ] no
I never forgot it like I was so like
just like now or like I remember exactly
what I was wearing last week I remember
it's just it was better memory actually
when I wasn't singing and then yeah they
would tell me I was doing stuff that was
so crazy and out of character for me
that like I would be embarrassed that
like that that story was real yeah like
I would if they confused you with like a
cousin or something no okay so like so
that's one me with my cousin Stephanie
oh really there's like 18 of us my
cousin spoke I live in Santa Barbara
they all lived in LA so I was the only
one that they could have dude one time I
got my ass kicked
cuz um there was like this so our house
is a two-story house and my mom came
home from the grocery store and I guess
there was like this kite and it like the
wind blew so then you could see like it
looked like someone was standing there
she came into the house she beat the
[ __ ] out of me she's like she's like how
are you gonna see me carrying all these
groceries and you're not gonna help me
you just went to hide I'm like what the
[ __ ] up and it was cuz of the Chi she
goes off [ __ ] I [ __ ] up I thought that
kite was you that's so like I like
they apologized yeah Wow my parents
would have never apologized it would
have been like will [ __ ] you should have
took [ __ ] clean up that kite yeah
it's still my fault
my dad's version of an apology as him
being like why he gotta make me mad and
he would do it all I do say [ __ ] up
like what what you gonna make me mad for
I'm like they're gonna say more things
why you gotta make me bad things yeah
but man it's so funny what was this
about of Grandma shooting the land oh
yeah I never had fucked-up relatives
like that did I know of my grandma would
hit us but I mean nothing like I feel
like I block out a lot of [ __ ] too cuz
my brother and my mom say that I got
[ __ ] up on my grandma and that [ __ ]
was weird like like I would say like I
would tell my grandma Alzheimer is now
yeah oh well we tell her like grandma
like this is between me and you like the
grades like don't tell anybody that I
[ __ ] up she's like I
I got your back and my mom was like oh
she pulled us that's why we [ __ ] you
up and I'm like what I thought it was
for other things they didn't even
explain to you why they're so many bad
things I guess I deserve track of which
one and my brother said one time he came
home and he saw my grandma riding me
like a horse and spanking my butt oh
damn cuz she was trying to like restrain
him is what I'm assuming
cuz I'm wild my butt was like this way
so my head was this way [ __ ] fine
yeah back in my butt like them like
[ __ ] beating my ass I don't even
remember any of that [ __ ] yeah and I
just love funny wild Brian Eno's it
being in trouble yeah like do we grow up
to be like that I hope I smoked a lot of
weed as a grandma cuz the discussion
goes up the older they go I'm a smoke
weed dude I'm modeling live in my
relation was opposite because my mom was
the [ __ ] so like my grandma always had
in my back
somebody mom can I eat fish but no
they're not gonna eat that I got Capri
Center something normal my grandma I'd
be like why not you gonna [ __ ] tell
your daughter I love my grandma I would
be my child's ass if he went from that
like I say no and then he asks someone
else oh okay good but then she would
just jump in oh that's like she were
just like eavesdropping or what why
can't he she puts up her chest man yeah
why can i huh
[Music]